se cierra el telón para uno de los
referentes del periodismo investigativo
independiente en rusia
fundada en 1993 nóvaya gazeta perdió su
licencia por lo tanto ya no tiene
permitido publicar noticias en el suelo
ruso el anuncio fue hecho por un
tribunal de moscú la versión oficial el
periódico no presentó los documentos
relativos a un cambio de propiedad en
2006 sin embargo para su redactor en
jefe la realidad es muy distinta
fue una decisión puramente política para
mí esta decisión despreciable y dirigida
no tiene ninguna base legal se nos
persigue porque supuestamente no hemos
presentado ciertos documentos cuando lo
hemos presentado todo
los problemas comenzaron el 15 de marzo
cuando el presidente ruso vladimir putin
aprobó una ley que castigaba con 15 años
de cárcel la difusión de información no
oficial sobre la guerra de ucrania la
soga continúa prestándose en abril
nóvaya gazeta suspendió sus
publicaciones por miedo a represalias
otra gran prueba para el medio
tristemente famoso por la muerte de
varios de sus redactores en particular
la de anna politovskaya asesinada en
2006 en el vestíbulo de su edificio en
moscú el futuro del periódico se escribe
ahora lejos de las fronteras de rusia en
abril varios miembros de la redacción se
exiliaron y lanzaron una edición europea
de subtítulo nóvaya gazeta europa